[Música]
noval justice now que es justamente una
ong internacional en 2015 nos dio un
dato impactante de las 200 entidades
económicas existentes en el mundo 153
eran empresas y solamente 47 eran países
esto qué significa que hoy empresas como
wal-mart generan riquezas anuales
equivalente al producto interno bruto de
bangladesh y vietnam juntos
que toyota genera riquezas en un solo
año equivalente a la riqueza anual de
chile
que sinopec y petrochina las
corporaciones petroleras más importantes
del gigante asiático generan riquezas
superiores al producto interno bruto de
perú de grecia y de portugal juntos
hoy el mundo le pertenece a las empresas
hoy las corporaciones dominan las
relaciones internacionales y a pesar de
esta información que realmente es
indiscutible todavía me encuentro en la
calle gente que cree que este binomio de
derechos humanos y empresas es un
sinsentido
a qué me refiero con esto en 2017 el
banco mundial
mencionó que en un período de 15 años
alrededor de 3.200 modificaciones a las
leyes en el mundo se dieron bien esto
qué significa que las empresas se están
volviendo el aliado número uno de los
gobiernos y por lo tanto esto tiene una
repercusión como la vean para bien pero
también puede ser para mal
al final del día
esta reflexión quiero quiero llevarlos a
un punto de partida y es que cuando
vamos a hablar de empresas y derechos
humanos vamos a entrar en un terreno
gris donde vamos a empezar justamente a
discutir cosas que pueden incluso
parecer contradictorias porque porque
existen argumentos muy poderosos y un
lado donde vamos a ver que menciona hay
un grupo grande enorme de la población
que cree que la empresa es un ente
depredador de la humanidad pero por otra
parte hay otro grupo de personas que
están convencidas que es a través del
empresariado como un cambio de fondo se
puede realizar ante la insuficiencia de
los gobiernos vamos a analizar estos
argumentos
la organización internacional oxfam este
año en su último reporte nos dio un dato
escalofriante y es que el 83 por ciento
de la riqueza a nivel mundial se
depositó únicamente en el 1% de la
población más rica del mundo esto qué
significa vamos a desmenuzar esta cifra
durante el 2017 un multimillonario nació
cada dos días ya ver no estoy diciendo
que estemos peleados con la riqueza a mí
me encanta la lana y creo que ustedes
también
sin embargo donde sí tenemos un problema
es en la distribución de la riqueza
saben si pudiéramos poner esto en pesos
y centavos cuánto significó este
crecimiento económico en 2017
pudimos haber terminado con la pobreza
extrema 7 veces
impactante
pudimos haberle puesto a los males
sociales de este mundo en 2017 si
hubiéramos distribuido la riqueza
efectivamente ahora es la parte mala
vamos a hablar de la parte buena a la
empresa como un ente generador de
beneficio social ya ver vamos a hacer un
pequeño ejercicio cuando hablamos de
tecnología y hoy vamos a hablar mucho de
tecnología en este foro tenemos una
falsa creencia de que la tecnología es
como terminator que está sustituyendo a
la humanidad y que nos está dejando en
la calle y que ya no vamos a tener
chamba en unos cuantos días sin embargo
eso es es un error
simplemente en 2012 esta gran firma de
especialistas financieros de lloyd hizo
un estudio en reino unido para poder
determinar el impacto de la tecnología
en los puestos de trabajo y encontró
algo impresionante de 1871 a 2011 se
generaron 10 veces más fuentes de empleo
que antes de esas fechas es decir la
tecnología genera muchos beneficios
porque porque abarata costos y los
costos disminuyen los precios y eso hace
que mi capacidad adquisitiva sea mayor y
pueda comprar mayores cosas y por lo
tanto tenga un excedente de dinero
interesante de parte cierto interesante
empezar a hablar de que si es bueno que
es malo pero justamente en este punto
podemos encontrar un punto convergente y
es que la empresa y los derechos humanos
si se necesitan de manera simbiótica la
empresa necesita la humanidad y la
humanidad necesita necesitar la empresa
y sobre ese punto es lo que quiero
hablarles el día de hoy simplemente
quiero hacer una pequeña introducción a
los derechos humanos por si alguien no
lo conoce hoy siempre he dicho que los
derechos
son el pitbull del derecho todo el mundo
habla de ellos
todo el mundo quiere tocar con pitbull
todo el mundo que habla de derechos
humanos bueno el tema de derechos
humanos es simplemente prerrogativas
naturales con las que nacemos por el
simple hecho de ser personas y que el
gobierno está obligado a respetar es
decir son garantías de nuestra
protección a la dignidad desde el poder
público pero la mejor manera de entender
esta interacción entre empresas y
derechos humanos es por un ejemplo y
necesito su participación levanten la
mano todos los que están aquí presentes
quién tiene un teléfono celular conocido
como smartphone quien tiene una levanten
la mano a ver perfecto vamos a jugar
quiero que desbloqueen su teléfono como
lo estoy haciendo yo se vayan justamente
a que la configuración abran
configuración y vayan el apartado de
general y en general se van a dar cuenta
que existe una función que dice
accesibilidad del clic ahora van a ver
una primera opción que dice voice over y
que se van a divertir mucho a ver qué
pasa
se van a dar cuenta que ahora el celular
les va a empezar a blas el celular les
está leyendo los contenidos que tienen
en su teléfono porque esta es una
aplicación para personas con
discapacidad visual hoy el celular es el
mejor dispositivo de inclusión que
pueden tener en su bolsillo hoy el
celular genera que las personas con
discapacidad visual que viven con
ceguera puedan hacer una llamada sin
ninguna complicación interesante verdad
ahora vuelvan a ver ese celular tómenlo
otra vez y piquen le empiecen a jugar
con el celular a ver que encuentran hace
15 años se acordarán que había celulares
con teclas de goma cierto hoy ya no hay
celulares con teclas de goma porque todo
es touch screen y el touch screen es una
maravilla porque nos ha facilitado la
comunicación y esto se da gracias a algo
llamado coltán y cobalto el coltán y
cobalto son minerales que se extraen en
la república democrática del congo vean
este vídeo cada vez que ustedes están
mandando un whatsapp
un niño en el congo está perdiendo la
vida
alrededor de 40 mil niños en república
democrática del congo y en uganda son
explotados anualmente para obtener este
mineral que se llama cobalto y coltán
para que su teléfono celular pueda
servir para mandar un whatsapp vean ese
vídeo cada vez que hacen una llamada
están promoviendo la esclavitud infantil
vuelvan a ver ese vídeo cada vez que
están revisando un correo electrónico en
su teléfono este niño está perdiendo su
infancia
impactante es una dualidad difícil y
compleja de comprender un mismo aparato
abre la llave de acceso a las personas
con discapacidad a la comunicación pero
el mismo aparato está generando que un
niño muera en la república democrática
del congo cada año
esto es una invitar una invitación a una
reflexión y es que esta dualidad
necesita entenderse desde el ámbito de
la corresponsabilidad de quién es la
culpa de las empresas de nosotros por
tener un celular o del gobierno
la respuesta es de todos es de los tres
tenemos actualmente que entender que el
gobierno es corresponsable porque no
está combatiendo y no está permitiendo
que ese niño que nos mide en la pantalla
vaya a una escuela la empresa porque
quiere competir más agresivamente y está
buscando abaratar costos y entonces está
generando estas prácticas y el
consumidor es decir nosotros porque nos
importa un comino lo que pasa cada vez
que compramos un celular es un esquema
de co-responsabilidad
ahora bien esta corresponsabilidad me
lleva a una segunda reflexión y es que
será posible que un mundo regido por el
libre mercado genere inclusión y apoyo a
la comunidad la respuesta es un sí
definitivo sin embargo tenemos también
que hablar que la empresa no es la
culpable de esto si la empresa está
generando estos productos es porque
existe una demanda en el mercado el
mercado genera necesidades y estas
necesidades están llevando a la empresa
a dar esa esa oferta de productos y
servicios usen su imaginación
vamos a usar nuestra imaginación
recuerden a ese cavernícola que hace
varios años hace millones de años
necesitaba cazar a un gran mamut y ese
gran mamut era tan grande que no podía
ser cazado por una sola persona que hizo
la persona que hizo ese cavernícola se
asoció con alguien y pum
surgió la primera empresa la empresa
nace gracias a la libertad de asociación
colectiva y eso se le está olvidando a
la empresa pero ojo las necesidades
colectivas tienen también un culpable y
eso somos los consumidores que también
hemos caído en incentivos perversos y
hemos creado falsas necesidades de
consumo lo cual nos ha llevado a generar
mercados digamos un poco desvirtuados a
qué me refiero imaginemos que yo tengo
una computadora en este momento y
entonces abro mi buscador en google y
voy a teclear un nombre muy raro ahí lo
van a ver en pantalla este nombre muy
raro es wards son tools son interesantes
y lo primero que alguien estaría viendo
cuando vesta está esta reproducción en
google sería peace one son tours bueno
van a ver que se van a desplegar aquí un
sitio web que es el sitio web de una
compañía esta compañía se dedica a algo
llamado tanto turismo o turismo negro es
una empresa que te lleva a ver
a vivo ya todo color
ward son tours tiene una un sinfín de
ofertas de viajes quieren verte
viajecitos tiene vean lo siguiente los
pueden mandar a irak a beirut a méxico
ya distintas partes de áfrica
si ustedes quieren conocer cómo son los
balazos en la vida real
llámenlos seguramente se van a divertir
mucho sabían que existe esto increíble
verdad como en pleno siglo 21
hoy estamos teniendo empresas que
atienden estos mercados la respuesta es
que tenemos que mirar hacia la
corresponsabilidad
tenemos que realmente como consumidores
dejar de consumir basura tenemos que
realmente voltear al consumo responsable
y con perspectiva de derechos humanos y
esto no es algo nuevo no crea que me lo
estoy inventando realmente este debate
empezó en 1999 kofi annan el entonces
secretario general de la onu dijo en el
foro de davos que es un foro que
importantísimo de las relaciones
internacionales dijo algo muy
interesante en 1999 y dijo tenemos que
optar
por sumar la fuerza de los mercados con
la autoridad de los ideales universales
pero sobre todo tenemos que optar por
conciliar la capacidad creativa de la
empresa privada con las necesidades de
los más desafortunados y las exigencias
de las generaciones futuras
wow tenemos que colaborar tenemos que
ser corresponsables y la empresa tiene
un poder tremendo para transformar a la
sociedad solamente tenemos que dar una
ayudita y esa ayudita significa ponerla
en cintura como lo vamos a hacer vamos a
poner tres ejemplos en eeuu desde el año
pasado las grandes empresas de redes
sociales ya están obligadas a comprobar
ante la autoridad que no están
promoviendo en la contratación de
publicidad
estará abonando a la trata y explotación
sexual de personas si ellos reciben un
pago de alguien que está explotando a
una persona y usa las redes sociales
para manifestar eso puede ser demandada
con responsablemente en reinounido las
grandes transnacionales necesitan
auditar
anualmente sus cadenas de producción y
sus cadenas de suministro para poder
corroborar a la autoridad hacendaria que
están esas cadenas están libres de
esclavitud infantil y en españa'
si ustedes quieren entrar a competir al
mercado de valores español van a
necesitar generar políticas de inclusión
de grupos en situación de vulnerabilidad
y política de respeto a los derechos
humanos desde la empresa hacia afuera
aquí viene casi el final de mi
comentario y es que la empresa tiene dos
opciones entrarle a la buena y eso es
asumiendo voluntariamente compromisos de
derechos humanos oa la mala apunta de
demandas pero al final del día le va a
terminar entrando y en eso nosotros
tenemos que empezar a empujar
soy un auténtico convencido de que es
posible desmentir esa vieja idea de que
ayudar al prójimo empobrece porque
porque la empresa necesita de
consumidores y si un día éstos
desaparecen o pierden la capacidad
adquisitiva a quién le van a vender
apostarle a un respeto de los derechos
humanos desde la gestión empresarial
oigan bien es apostarle a preservar la
existencia de la propia empresa pero
también a estrechar ya solidificar una
relación de negocios con el consumidor
si yo procuro al consumidor si yo
procuro al entorno
estoy estrechando mi lazo comercial con
mi comprador
no es tan difícil es sencillo es viable
solamente se necesita de unas cosas muy
sencilla voluntad
hoy estoy cierto y se los digo
mirándolos a todos estoy cierto de que
hacer negocios abonando a un mundo más
justo e incluyente definitivamente es
posible y así es como se llama mi
conferencia que lo que se necesita para
hacer esto redescubrir el objeto social
de la empresa muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]